this says Mona Lisa but it also is Mona
Lisa you'd better rearrange yourself
because this is episode 53 of IMG
less posito thorisi invented this form
of constrained writing he calls them
panachograms when you hear the beep you
will have been watching this video for
23 seconds but if you've been watching
it upside down also 23 seconds
ambigrams are awesome but also they're
awesome I can see that you like twists
and turns so let's turn around the
actual Mona Lisa this is the back of the
world's most famous painting Aaron Kuhn
made this image it's a typogram because
the words both label the parts and are
the parts stop is that an octagon Smooth
Move Euclid octagons inhabit
two-dimensional planes stop signs have
extension in our three-dimensional world
so a stop sign is actually a very very
thin octagonal prism